Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Bist du aufgeregt? Dein Kanzler ist in Washington DC.
Ja, ich hoffe, wir bekommen wieder great television zu sehen.
Ich glaube, sie werden sich Mühe geben.
Vermutlich, ja. Ich könnte es mir auch vorstellen. Wir werden, wenn es besonders interessant wird, das natürlich am Ende des Monats.
Da kommt heute Abend noch das Update zum Besuch.
Ja.
Und wir beginnen jetzt.
Genau. Nein, so schlimm wird es wahrscheinlich nicht werden oder so interessant wird es auch nicht. Mal schauen, weil man weiß ja nie, was der Monat uns noch bringt. Aber wir haben es ja damit einem Präsidenten zu tun, der offenbar noch sehr fit ist. Bei Joe Biden sah das anders aus. Und wir haben ja jetzt eine große Debatte um Joe Biden deshalb, weil es ein Buch gibt von Jake Tapper, der ist von CNN, der ein Buch geschrieben hat über diese Ursünde, wie er es nennt, dass man bei den Demokraten und auch in den Medien solange die Augen verschossen hat, davor wie der Gesundheitszustand von Joe Biden eigentlich ist. Als dieses Buch dann veröffentlicht wurde vor einigen Tagen, hat gleichzeitig die beiden Familie bekannt gegeben, dass Joe Biden an Krebs erkrankt ist. Man hat also damit auch natürlich mit diesem Buch ein bisschen Wind aus den Segeln genommen und gesagt, hier, ich spiele die Musik, das ist unser Thema jetzt hier. Nun gibt es natürlich viel Kritik auch an Jake Tapper. Zum einen, weil er als Journalist die ganze Zeit mitgearbeitet hat an dieser Ursünde und immer so getan hat, als sei mit Joe Biden alles super. Und er gehört mit CNN und mit den anderen daran andockenden Mainstream-Medien natürlich zu denen, die immer gesagt haben, das sind Verschwörungstheorien der Republikaner.